welcome to another stories from the
stores now today I'm joined by curator
Donata Miller
and she says it's time to show me
something very interesting so donata and
what's this this is a Chinese powdered
incense [ __ ] it's the clock that uses
incense and fire to tell the time it's
from the 1700s onwards so initially
incense clock would be used in temples
to tell the time with festivals say or
when certain ceremonies needs to take
place okay so with incense clocks they
all have this really cool symbol in the
middle
so not all incense clocks have this
symbol but the modern incense clocks
would often have a symbol of luck or
good well in the middle so this is a
character which is called strung sheet
and it's a character which has been
translated to me and Double Happiness
and it's a character which is often used
in Chinese culture and often related to
marriage something that scholars would
often use to feel inspired smoke come
through the grates and you know it just
looked great and yeah it will trigger
their emotions and imagination okay so
you talked about how it works can you
show me
so this clock has two different levels
here and it shows us a little maze
inside so we have these mazes there's
one that's more simple and one that's
more complex these mazes were told
different amounts of time so you would
use white words ash or you could also
use powdered incense to layer layer on
the tray and then press the maze imprint
into this white wood and ash and that
would leave a trail for its you to light
and measure the time with okay so you
watch it just watch it burn is how we do
so you can watch it burn but you can
smell it burning also so depending on
the material that you've put inside
you'd be able to smell it so what you're
telling me is I could just know it's
11:15 because the room smells like roses
basically yeah so why do you think it's
so important that the museum has
something like this I think it shows a
type of time measurement that we're not
used to seeing and it really shows that
Western culture doesn't own time
and that people from different cultures
and different societies have been
telling times in many different ways for
a very very long time